breaking news we are following tonight A
Pursuit culminating in the first
officer-involved shooting of 2023 right
next to the Galleria Mall thank you for
joining us on 8 news now at 11 I'm Brian
Loftus now at carjacking near Saharan
Paradise sparking and Chase that led
officers to Sunset and Stephanie that's
where we find reporter Brian will now
live with more Brian
yeah that shooting happened right behind
me where you can see the wrecked vehicle
the suspect was driving police say it
all started when officers located a
stolen vehicle near Sahara and Paradise
and tried to pull the vehicle over a
Chase then ensued until the vehicle
collided with a car here at Sunset and
Stephanie in Henderson officers say he
then got out of the car and fled on foot
with a gun in his hand
officers discharged their firearm
striking
the suspect suspect was tended to by
medical and transported to Sunrise
Hospital and is currently in critical
condition
police say the vehicle the suspect was
in was stolen earlier the day and used
in a robbery and we're also learning
tonight that that vehicle that the
suspect collided with there were two
people in there and they were injured
but we don't know the extent of their
injuries tonight live in Henderson Brian
will eight news now